are we always follow Christ because what
Peter said we must do Hebrew is like
slave 400 years in Egypt yeah are we as
full of Christ no people saying oh most
the word Muslim means submit
um submit to one God say yes we submit
to the one according to God according
wait a second Muslim mean in Arabic
Islam
which means in English to submit Allah
to the wall of Allah right towards
without any partner and to surrender to
him and by obeying his messenger and to
free ourselves from paganism and his
people good
good
paganism on people
since
I believe
um maybe live in one God you understand
one God who is that God who is the god
that you believe in Abraham Jacob is
that Jesus yeah
Jesus is the son can't be the father
when Jesus said me and the father one
and him said me and the father one but
I'm not the father because there's
somebody who's greater than him but they
saw so so step by step step by step to
understand each other yeah
don't know you get me listen
look
scripture when Jesus said I and the
father are one right would you
understand from that
when we understand from means just as he
said when you see me you see the father
if you love me you love the father you
love the father Yes
basically the Father the father can
imagine the father coming coming come
into this world with all these Powers
all of us
no
the Bible teacher said Christ is the
greatest
um creation of the father father
creating you understand
Jesus just 61. when Jesus said I am the
father are one yes is there are what in
essence or in purpose in everything
there can't be never in everything
that's a good point why they cannot be
in everything because this passage it
has been explained in mother's passage
Jesus said to his disciples one he said
just as I and the father are one right
our praise the father you'll be one with
us right of course disciples are not one
in essence with God they are one in
purpose meaning that the the father
would say I will explain to you why this
term was used back with the Israelites
there's no actual father in Islam
teaching which church we abstain from
that because it cause confusion you
understand so listen to this so in
purpose meaning God wants us to worship
him alone follow his teaching Jesus
that's why he came to teach us his
disciples that's what they want not in
essence because Jesus said amen Jesus
said the father is greater than I right
all right therefore there cannot be one
Essence because if me and you won asses
No One's Gonna Be greater than the other
one because somebody said somebody said
when you see me you see the father me
I'm a father I want you gonna believe
that no because
when Jesus said before that remember I
spoke to you last week or two weeks ago
that I don't accept everything in the
Bible and I told you why from inside
sources and outside sources best upon
history I can explain to you why the
Bible cannot be trusted but let us go to
the the passage when Jesus said if you
see me see the father
any human being speak okay is the
does the father look like a
an Israelite uh with a nose a thief and
so on no yes yes he does so so the funny
human being yes oh no you won't be
anything let's make man in our image so
God create Us in His image no it's an
image created well that's why that's the
reason why he came before when he saw
when he visited no no when when he
visited Abraham who visit Abraham
Andrews no God no God no God no no no no
no no no no no no no no no
why why why I'm boredom
right here
overcome I know but let me tell you
something explain to you to show you
about the Bible so now we have to
understand when Jesus said if you see
about the God created the man in his own
image okay we have similar statements in
our Islamic sources what does that mean
does that mean because human being means
we have a knowledge God has a knowledge
okay we have a power God has a power we
have the hand God has the hand to it
with his majesty we know there's nothing
look like God at all God is the Creator
and we are the creation that's why Isla
you need
that's why we need you need and everyone
needs the Christians the Jewish the
Israelites they need Quran and Islam to
rectify and clarify and refute the
doubts and the lies that that has been
attribute to God in the Old Testament
and explained that which is unclear from
there when God said let us create even
our own image no mean God is like human
being or is like us he gets sick tired
no Allah
and Allah has to hear him and we have a
hearing but Allah is hearing no like
Allah's hearing is perfect our head is
deficient Allah sees and we see that
Allah sees is perfect and while
imperfect Allah has a knowledge we have
a knowledge so it's the same but not
saving everything Allah's knowledge is
perfect our knowledge is imperfect the
other thing I want to mention to you
that remember that I remember that one
or city bro the Old Testament you cannot
trust it so if you say God came to
Abraham I said no the Quran is the
criteria over the Bible why because the
Old Testament cannot be trusted and can
I prove that to you the Old Testament
teach you that God was scared from his
people that doesn't make any sense to
any human being because God is not
scared of anything and of anyone if you
go to Genesis let me ask you how the
language came about
all the language came about yeah
why we speak different languages
where we speak different languages yes
open Genesis 9 11. no no let me tell you
let me tell you
why we speak languages
God make us speak different languages so
that we cannot understand each other
because remember I think the King was
built building a big tower to reach to
God in Genesis God confused
um confuse the people and that's why
they wrote Babylon so you're scared I
mean confusion so so so so it make us
start to speak different language
because you're scared because we
couldn't understand each other we start
separate and go to other places to live
that's why what's this
intellectually that's what I said all
the time bro I said what distinguished
Islam from any religion or way of life
that Islam goes in line with the sound
reasoning with the creator has given to
all of us that's why Islam that's why
people naturally are inclined towards
Islam to go back to why we speak
different languages in Genesis it says
that God looked upon the Earth and he
saw people speaking I saw people
speaking one language
and they start building 12 buildings and
he said human speak one language and
start building some buildings so nothing
can stop them and this is this
so God God sent the angel to cause
confusion in order for the people yes
because this doesn't make any sense you
know why because
I'm gonna explain to you to understand
because I say that yes
I'll tell you what does it make sense
because this teaching it it comes from
the Sumerians Sumerians believed that if
you build two buildings you'll be able
to reach God we know now for facts
regardless how tall your building you
will never be able to reach God so God
will scare some people they're gonna
reach him but we know they cannot reach
him so God is ignorance that is so high
no one can reach him yeah scriptures
foreign
I believe in the scripture when he says
when Moses said to the people worship
God alone I accept that I believe I
believe that Moses split the sea I
accept that I believe that Allah favored
the Israelites over other nations I
accept the other time that is in the
Quran by the way however the certain
things any human being will accept it
because I'm not gonna worship God that
was scared because people spoke one
language compared this teaching in the
Old Testament when our teaching Islam
Prophet Muhammad mentioned if all
Manchester
United because he was scared that's what
he said he said before he said he said
he looked upon the Earth and he saw
people speaking one language right
speaking what one language and he said
they start speaking one language and
they start building two buildings
nothing can stop them so what he did he
says we know human many things
check it out
I love Ginger
yeah nine eleven or eleven nine
someone can check your house I speak in
different languages isn't it is in
Genesis I'm sure so in me out here so
God God is that freaking that's not
speaking one language nothing can stop
them so he starts confusing them because
they're building two buildings look to
the Islamic teaching Prophet Muhammad
said if all mankind everyone and the
demon they are the most evil hearts that
will not scare Allah
[Music]
and if all mankind every human being who
has the most Indians
read the whole Bible no problem
Muhammad said if all mankind have the
most Pious righteous hearts that will
not benefit Allah if it's in Islam do
not want to speak different language is
America from Allah not because Allah was
worried people spoke one language he
could confuse them so read it now read
it out I read it from
already from five and the Lord came down
to see the city and the tower which the
children of no no no before the people
thanks
we can't just read one scripture no no
no
so that we can get the full
understanding
from the beginning
[Music]
with you
foreign
[Music]
language one of one language and it came
to pass as they journeyed from East that
they found a place in the land of what
is word senior and age 12 tier and they
said one
to another God to let us make bricks
and burn and burn them totally and and
they add bricks
and day foreign
let me read it for you to understand
[Music]
let us make brick and burn them
thoroughly right and they had brick for
stone right slime and had they for more
time and they said go to let us build us
a city and a tower right whose top May
reach unto heaven right and let us make
us a name lest we be scattered abroad
yes upon the face of the whole earth
right and the Lord the Lord came down to
see the city and the tower which the
children of men built right and the Lord
said behold the people is one and they
have all one language and this they
begin to do and now nothing will be
restrained from them so what was this
course
language
what was he worried about
what happened to say was worried yeah
yeah
and the Lord said behold the people is
one and they are all one language one
language and this is they began to do
yes now nothing will be restrained from
them yeah
right go to let us down and then
confound their language and they might
not understand what another speech so
the Lord scattered them abroad from the
the sorry there's not a phase one yeah
upon the face of all the earth and the
city therefore is the name of it
because the Lord did that confront the
language of all the Earth and from there
that's did the Lord scattered them
abroad upon the face of all the Earth
this is our generation so here go
history of people wearing this scripture
said God was scared why he was scared
why confused them no problem why confuse
them
all right
because they was doing something
right which one which is building tall
buildings
God said nothing can stop them
nothing will be restrained from them
that's simple
they're gonna build a lot of tall
buildings nothing cannot stop them no
okay okay
so they don't understand each other and
when they realize that they don't
understand each other then start to
separate it and no you know I'll tell
you why I'll tell different places to
live I'll tell you no you know
but then but then there wasn't a lot of
tall buildings no no no no no no there's
a lot of buildings building now
speaking different languages
the Sumerians they used to believe if
you beat two buildings you can reach God
and we know regardless how tall your
building is you will never be able to
reach anything you have to let me finish
yeah yes regardless how much you build
two buildings you will never be able to
reach God so describe who wrote this
passage you can see his ignorance that
the sky is so high regardless how much
we build two buildings so that's not
from God no way God stop people speak in
one language they speak a language one
language two buildings nothing can stop
them what do you mean
he said nothing can stop them regardless
what people would do that will never
worry Allah
[Music]
the people of fruits the people float
because they're doing a cry against God
you understand not because God is like
they speak in one language doing virtual
buildings no you have to understand this
passage this passage it goes back to the
Pagan teaching
you know what I'm gonna say something to
you you see
we are really spiral you agree on some
things but some things they don't agree
on
you see when we read the Quran we agree
on some things and some things middle
one like what so you see the confusion
there there's no confusion because
you cannot trust it you you can't trust
it you cannot trust it you cannot trust
okay what is the earliest I believe why
could I trust you see a key and Justice
I'll tell you what I'll tell you I know
I tell you I'll tell you why you know
okay no no no no don't expect me about
my book
no problem no problem you can do that no
problem
you're the Bible that you have yes you
have Old Testament okay what language
Moses spoke
okay yeah yeah no problem
Egyptian for 400 years
second thing the earliest manuscript for
the Torah the five books that we have is
there's one thousand years gap between
Moses and the the writer do you know
describes who wrote the earliest
manuscript that is 1 000 years between
Moses and the right do you know his name
can you trust me if you don't know him
if I can trust him if I don't know him
yeah
someone you don't know what so why why
are you trusting a book when you read
this book when I read this book yeah we
always trust this book so when you read
it
smoke I'm gonna look in this book I can
see me you can see what I can't say me I
can't see him but in the middle you can
see yourself
I can't see my people no when when you
read the current maybe you can see your
people no I can't see my people here as
well I can't see myself here too that's
the reason why I trust is that's not a
bad reason come on man you can see me
anymore
and everything what's going on in the
world right now and what happened to my
people but then it was all written no
this is true
inside let's go to great that's good
regrets does God regret yes regret why
is it good explain
regrets yeah meaning that you do
something and and you and and you you
you you regret from doing because
because you're too upset from doing it
you didn't want to do it
because it was a mistake because it was
a mistake because they regret to it yeah
you can't say we can't say we can't say
we can't say we can't say what it it was
a regret because
they're gonna do that
no no no no
come after yourself
yeah remember we're gonna stand before
the Creator the most high this is
what we're doing here maybe sometimes we
joke yeah but it's a serious matter you
know
there's no problem make a joke it's a
serious matter you're gonna stand before
the Creator the truth is one you know
Creator is not also of confusion you
understand let's go back to the main
point will you regret something give you
example one second one second imagine
I go I come back he took my phone as I
greatly regret for letting my phone with
Muhammad why because I'm deficient in my
knowledge I didn't know he was going to
take it so we regret it goes back to
deficiency of knowledge so when God in
the Bible said God greatly regrets for
choosing Soul as a king who chose him is
God so God regrets his own
actions
I will make attack I'm not gonna say
that you cannot make any Stroke
by myself no no yes
his own action that shows you his
deficiency in his knowledge but Allah
told us he knows everything all the
times
the outcome of something because Allah
knows the outcome of everything
there's many passages within the Bible
show you those Through the Bible that
have hatred against God and hatred and
guess the prophets of God and I can show
you more and more and more but that is
sufficient for anyone who has a sound
reasoning and a sound heart
something
and you don't do it and get fixed no
requests
gonna go the other way God knows
everything so why do you regret that
knows everything so why do you regret
God knows everything and yes
because he regrets because Saul didn't
listen to him
go to regrets own action he did it no
Paul no soul he chose him God chose him
he's no soul he said I greatly regret
for choosing for my own action no
problem no soul I mean God did something
else
upon wisdom and knowledge when God does
an action he does an action based upon
wisdom Justice knowledge Mercy based
upon knowledge no best upon ignorance so
if God does something then he regrets
all action therefore he didn't know that
his own action is gonna the outcome of
it it's gonna go against him come on man
what you're saying is almighty God of
this book give us freedom of choice
asking
and Saul go against him as we in this
world sometimes go against God and sin
no no there's no sins
knows everything so what you're saying
in your book in your book God knows
everything so what you're saying if God
knows that I am gonna gonna go against
him he wouldn't choose me as a king
because they know everything no he will
not regressing who if you choose
if God choose me as being a king and I
go against him he wouldn't have no Grace
what I'm saying that I'm not saying if
God choose someone I'm saying God
regretting his own action of choosing no
you if you understand for example look
let me go like for example go that there
was scholar in the Quran this corner God
bless him with knowledge then he was
against God Allah never said he
regretted it because all I know he's
gonna go and guess him he know this man
he used to show off in the sense so my
point here is
the king he told Solomon to do something
and Solomon didn't do it no I don't
believe in the Bible there's some stuff
in there I don't believe I don't believe
I don't believe
there's a lot of things you don't
believe in them I'll tell you what I'll
tell you why yeah
you have daughters okay Allah bless them
I have a teacher
is going to teach your daughter and your
family but guess this teacher he rapes
women this teacher he killed people and
Justice Give an example imagine as a
teacher are you looking for English
teacher so I said this art English
teacher for your family yeah but guess
what this English teacher he lies he
killed innocent people he kills children
right he raped a woman right would you
allow him to teach your family no I
wouldn't I wouldn't allow them so are
you are you more wiser than God
so how come God choose a prophet like
David who he lied he could innocent
people he sets up his own across the
Bible according to us we don't believe
that he lied he he killed innocent
people he set up his own friend that
defended him to go sleep with his wife
so God chose the evil man
what you know
as a robot
he made us freedom of choice to choose
now if God choose me to be a king and
and then and then one day me go against
God is that is
Prophet Prophet are the best people but
I will read that all the prophets
all the prophets all of them the best
thing wasn't perfect
God no no no choose them choose them to
be a prophet because when you are white
you know why it should stay
in God
no David
you will not choose the future direct
women said
um
David is a man of him own heart right
God said that you know what someone can
hold up
everything that they will do and they
and David speak to the Lord David follow
exactly what the Lord said
this Rhymes yes
but sometimes you do something that
you're not supposed to do okay right can
I sometimes do it
you go and you pray and ask Allah to
forgive you that's right we are not
perfectly now we are not perfect careful
enough all these prophets are gonna
appointed to be to be to be Prophets
[Music]
if you don't even choose English teacher
to teach your own family because this
man is a liar an evil man
it's my time it's my time it's my time
please I'll let you speak yes so how God
the most wise will choose a liar
murderer to convey the message of God do
you know what humans will say hang on
this man is a liar murderer rapist and
we're gonna trust him so they will have
excuse for rejecting the prophets of God
but we not in the quranic teaching the
prophets of God all of them they will
not to be trustworthy truthful and
honest why in order for the people to
have no excuse and guess the prophets
because they know hang on this man is a
trustworth is known all this person let
me finish a truthful person so in the
Quran the prophets of God are the
Israelite prophets other than Israelites
were highly respected they're not
perfect in a way when you say they do
forget but they will never commit a
major sin or a sin or disobey God
and how to teach you Islam because allow
the sound reasoning and natural
inclination bro you're reading a Bible
the book I told you that some stuff I
accept but some stuff is impossible to
accept it's impossible for me as a human
being I know
you don't understand
things
there are certain things in the para
that impossible you have to finish
foreign
[Music]
things in your current
I I I'm not gonna accept Okay because
explain it to me okay
you're not you're not accept certainly
let me tell you why let me tell you no
no no no no no no no
let me tell you saying that you believe
what you want to believe I may believe
what mean you have to believe
you worship what you want for us
no problem what we say to you if you
accept them if you have a mind right
don't accept the Bible your mind will
accept anything
foreign
[Music]
kill me
of me
they're making my people to rushing by
and sing you're finished why don't you
go and do it I'll tell you you could do
something wouldn't you go and do it let
me speak now yes let me speak wouldn't
you go and do it of course guys of
course God of course of course
I know natural disaster but that's from
God but what I'm talking about I don't
believe God will tell me to slaughter a
baby for something happened 500 years
ago y'all never do the baby Allah
will not hold you accountable for sins
of your fathers live a lot of sins
something happened 500 years ago
likewise Prophet Muhammad taught us in
the war in the world
children don't chase a man who has no
weapon but in your Bible kill the babies
so to the babies what happened if Isis
they were teaching and learning the
Bible not the Quran the Quran is
merciful Mankind and also yes with the
world in Islam which is the praise where
the world which one word that remove
oppression by protecting women and
children and defeating the tyrants but
you were in your books is bringing up
oppression killing the babies and
infants and women
know yourself
my God will not tell me to kill a baby
for example my country was invaded by
France for 1 to 32 years that was in
like in the eight and in the 60s
have respect please let me understand my
to go to France now and kill the French
baby
because oshmc the French 130 100 years
they were killing people Allah is the
most just if you kill me if you start to
kill me I'll protect myself and I will
kill you no problem with that said I
will not kill babies or your woman your
wife because all your children
here yes we have a problem here we have
a problem here you're a book and my book
is a problem
but guess what I will come back with
this scriptures then I will show you
yeah you you you you need to you need to
explain Allah will never starts to kill
a baby
because maybe I'll tell you I can help
you a story of such gas the stone
started cast the young boy it was a
child by the way he was a young boy why
because himself he was growing up to
kill and to commit crime and to harm his
family not because you killed that young
boy because 500 years ago happened to
understand that's why Islam is based
upon Justice and mercy and wisdom that's
what I said to you in the beginning you
don't know who wrote it those who wrote
the Bible that the hatred and just God
himself
to them
anyway my dear brothers and sisters uh
some of you don't know we are doing
campaign to raise the money for our to
buy new Masjid I mean some of you maybe
have been or visited our mission
literally we have a small place like one
room all right and it's in the back of
the market and uh subhanallah the
Alleyways sometimes get nasty you know
literally we had to rent a new place to
open a school for the children to come
people get scared they understand so we
are doing campaign we make sure you come
to check on our Channel what's the name
of the message
so I help you Brothers may Allah bless
you all and we ask that's Clear Proof
sorry don't give us money better that's
why we're asking you is money wouldn't
ask you
welcome